let's listen evolved into what this
modern mess that women have become well
well no not evolve into a modern
Mastermind I've become those are the
women that this red pill situation talks
about I'm talking about an involved
woman that can actually stand by her
man's side and help him do anything a
woman that can actually be able to pick
up a new skill to support her man a
woman that can actually say you know
what babe these things are not okay go
out there and hustle I got I got is on
this side and that is not a stupid woman
that's exactly that's exactly what I
just described
well then you've rejected the fact that
I said I want to make that as
intellectual because I'm smart too